[موسيقى]
كانت حرائق ليل الخميس ما زالت
تُشعل وتُطفأ ولكن في ضواحي موريا ، كانت
حالة الطوارئ الوحيدة المهمة الآن هي الحالة
الإنسانية التي
لا يزال الآلاف من اللاجئين محاصرين بها من
قبل الشرطة
ولكن الآن بدون أي ملاذ على الإطلاق ، أصبح الأمر على
بعد أميال وأميال  من البؤس البشري
الممتد على طول هذه الطرق حول
ما كان مخيم موريا للمهاجرين
، ألق نظرة هنا يمكنك أن ترى
العائلات تفعل ما في وسعها
لمحاولة العثور على مأوى والحفاظ على
دفء أنفسهم لأن الأمسيات تكون
باردة جدًا هنا على الرغم من أن الأيام
جميلة
يمكنك أن ترى أنه تم إخبار هؤلاء النساء هنا
بالوقوف في طوابير
لأن الطعام سيُحضر بشاحنة
ثم وصلوا واندفع الجميع
لمحاولة الحصول
على شيء للكثيرين ، كانت هذه أول
علامة على المساعدة التي حصلوا عليها منذ الحريق
يوم الثلاثاء  الليل حرمهم من
القليل الذي كانوا يمتلكونه
أثناء فرارهم ، التقط العديد منهم مقاطع فيديو بينما
تصاعد الدخان
في ملاجئهم.
تعيش عائلتي الآن بين الموتى ،
فقدنا كل شيء مثل
الملابس والأدوية. أمي
مثل الآخرين هنا يخبروننا أنهم
لا يعتقدون أن المهاجرين كانوا
مسؤولين عن الحريق
حتى عندما قالت السلطات اليونانية إن
المهاجرين غاضبون من الحريق.  القيود المتعلقة بـ covet 19 التي
أعلم أنها كانت الفاشية
لأنني رأيت في المرة الثانية
أن اليونانيين على الدراجة النارية
كانوا
قادمين وكانوا حول المخيم
وفعلوا ذلك قالوا إن
اللاجئ يفعل ذلك ولكن هذا ليس صحيحًا
لأن اللاجئين  لا يمكنني القيام بذلك ،
يقدر عدد الأشخاص
الذين كانوا يعيشون في موريا بـ 13000 شخص ، ويقول أولئك الذين
يعرفون المخيم
إن الظروف في الداخل كانت مروعة ، لقد
كنت هنا في عام 2018 وكذلك في عام 2019 ،
واعتقدت في ذلك الوقت أنه لا يمكن
أن يزداد الأمر سوءًا.
هنا الآن في عام 2020 وكنت مخطئًا ،
فالأمر أسوأ
، آه بالنسبة للأطفال أيضًا ،
نتحدث عن الأطفال الذين
ربما لم يعرفوا أبدًا أي شيء سوى
الحرب والآن يتعرض مستقبلهم مرة
أخرى للتمزيق  بعيدًا عنهم
في الوقت الحالي ، فإن مستقبلهم المباشر
هو الأكثر إثارة للقلق
في موريا ، حيث كان لديهم طعام وماء هنا
في المقبرة
، وليس لديهم أي شيء على الإطلاق ميليسا بيل
سيينا lesbos